hey so guys my name is China we're back
with the code review of the game with
the flying dog just another day at the
office uh the previous episode will be
linked up there because this is a
continuation of that last episode still
reviewing the same code here we are so
what do we end on last time it was the
textures yeah so here we were in the
game class inside game in it that's what
was loading all these textures and
that's where we kind of stopped last
time so getting back to this file let's
keep looking at what happened so so this
is like the bulk of the initialization
code the update function is kind of part
of our game Loop so this is what kind of
gets executed every single frame now the
first thing I can notice you're doing
here is you're passing in frame start
which is a 32-bit unsigned integer and
you're passing it by const reference
which is not something you want to do
and in fact I can see that in a few
different places now this like at the
end of the day is not a huge deal but I
would drop this like habit immediately
if you have a type that is trivially
copyable and is kind of small enough
then
you should always pass that type by
value what I mean is on a 64-bit
architecture here so we're building this
in x64 and this CPU is a 64-bit CPU like
pretty much all CPUs are these days
what's actually happening is by kind of
passing this as a const reference what
really has to happen is this kind of
argument gets converted into a pointer
right because that's kind of what a
reference is at the end of the day it's
like kind of syntactic sugar around
really what is a memory address a
pointer so you're not kind of passing
the uint itself the value of the integer
you're passing its location in memory so
that you can then kind of reference it
and it's referencing that same exact
kind of variable now how big a point is
on a 64-bit architecture 64 bits so this
becomes eight bytes that you're actually
passing here how big is a un32 it's four
bytes so basically instead of just
copying the value of this into this
function which is less memory you're
kind of up converting it into a pointer
and then having to kind of I guess deal
with it as if it was like a reference
and a pointer rather than just a simple
value of memory that can easily be
loaded into a CPU register now I don't
want to get too deep into here I will
say that this is this is actually a
really good topic for me to probably
make a big video about I'm going to
write that down but all I'm saying is
that as a rule if you have something
that is well especially less than eight
bytes of memory but possibly even less
than 16 or 32 bytes of memory this is
really where if it really matters to you
it's like a very hot path you want to
probably do some profiling on your
device whatever it is that you're going
to be executing the code on to just see
how it works as well as what the
compiler decides to do with these things
again this is endlessly complex and I
don't want to get too into it but if you
have something that is small enough you
should just pass it by value which would
look like this
because obviously when you pass
something by const reference there's a
special type of reference that obviously
you're not really supposed to modify
even though you can actually cast the
const away and do whatever you want with
it because you have the reference you
have the block of memory you can
actually edit it you can mutate it
that's kind of on you even though you're
kind of saying you won't by putting
const here but my point is because the
const is here it kind of like the
meaning that it assigns to this is that
I'm just I just need to read this value
I don't need to actually modify it
therefore just copy it now this doesn't
just include primitive types like a
un-32 which speaking of which I wouldn't
use this this kind of weird Alias for it
which is I guess in sdl I actually
didn't even know this was a thing I
would definitely just use the built-in
kind of C plus plus type which is un32
underscore T so use that instead of the
sdl type that for one will make your
code style I guess compatible with
anything that is written in C plus plus
and you can see they're exactly the same
like if I go to the definition of this
it is in fact that which is yeah I mean
to be expected and that is going to be
like a built-in compiler type for msvc
but really it's just going to be an
unsigned ant just got dark in here one
other thing I was going to say is yeah
so it's not just about primitive types
like if you had a struct here that was
like you know some custom type obviously
and then it like internally maybe had
like I don't know two un32ts which again
is like 64 bits technically and you
passed that as well I probably wouldn't
choose to pass that custom type by kind
of constant reference like that I would
instead get rid of it get rid of like
the const reference and just pass it by
value because this custom type is just
2u and 32ts which again fundamentally in
memory is the same thing as if you just
passed a single un604t like that it's
exactly the same now what I said earlier
about trivially copyable is also kind of
I guess important to note
um so what I mean by that is when a type
isn't trivially copyable which I feel
like that's a real term right I didn't
just make that up but basically we have
something called a copy Constructor
which is basically
something that every class or struct
kind of has implicitly but then you can
also override it if you need custom
Behavior so a good example of that might
be maybe we have like some kind of data
buffer here right and every time we kind
of copy this custom type we can't just
shallow copy the pointer because what
that would do is basically if we make a
copy of this right we have two of these
custom types pointing to exactly the
same kind of buffer and memory and
that's not great because it means that
like I don't know do they own that
buffer because if one of them dies then
it's going to delete that which is going
to suck for our second custom type
because now it's got no buffer so what
we usually want to do is when we make a
copy of it we want to say okay no you
don't do this you actually get your own
copy of that buffer which also
um probably drawing this right where the
FaceCam is
um I'm gonna do vertical text so what
that means among other things is that
when we actually delete this this
doesn't die but also it means that they
are two independent copies if we modify
it it also doesn't modify the other one
right we don't want to kind of share a
buffer almost as if it was static so
what we tend to do is instead of just
kind of letting this be a shallow copy
that ends up copying the pointer itself
meaning the memory address and now we
have two custom types pointing to a
single memory address instead we write
some code here to basically be like all
right well whatever the size of the
other buffer is let's create our new
buffer right so new un32tn maybe a
buffer size is like 64 bytes or 64 times
4 bytes actually so 256 bytes and then
what do we do we do like a mem copy
basically from other buffer into our one
and that would be you know size of uint
U into 32t times like 64 which is a
buffer size so that's kind of the full
picture this kind of functionality and
this kind of struct here now is not
trivially copyable or at least it's not
kind of because it's not straightforward
in a way right copying it is not as
simple as just basically taking like the
memory block that represents that struct
and copying it now we actually have to
run a function that's going to allocate
another block of memory and then copy
everything into it which obviously will
slow down our program that's extra work
that it needs to do so now even though
custom type is how big 64 bits right
like 8 bytes is the size of this type
and if we have an instance of it that
variable is 8 bytes it's just a pointer
however it has some extra kind of layers
to it which means that if I now take
that and I pass it by value into this
function then every time I pass it into
this function it has to make a copy of
it which means it has to run this
function and Heap allocate and copy a
bunch of memory so this would be a good
candidate for us to be like you know
what const reference that's not
something that I want to copy and that
kind of is hopefully a good example and
a good explanation of where I would kind
of pass things is by value meaning copy
them like this or when I would actually
pass them by const reference so if we go
to the thing that's calling this
function because of course you have to
get rid of the const reference here and
again I would rewrite this as just a u
and 32t like that nothing else changes
they're exactly the same type as you saw
before from looking up the definition
but then if we go to whatever calls
update which is game update over here
this also doesn't change because frame
start here is just like a un32 and we're
just passing it in here that's the other
interesting thing about const references
const references are special in the
sense that they can take in an L value
or an R value if you have no idea what L
values or R values or move semantics are
I have a few C plus videos about them
which I will also link up there and in
the description of this video as well
but basically what that means is if game
update takes in a const preference let's
kind of make it take in a const
reference again it can take in either an
L value which is an actual real variable
that we have here like frame start or we
can pass in an R value so like directly
like a literal value you know like two
for example and that will work fine
that's kind of a special feature of the
const reference if this was just a
normal reference like this without the
const this would actually give us an
error because it has to be an L value
since we might you know modify it in the
update function and what do you can't
modify to it doesn't really exist it's
like a temporary value now the reason
I'm explaining this is because it means
that if you want to switch from a const
reference to a by value situation like
this it's dead simple you just do what I
just did there you just remove it
because whoever uses this function it
accepts either an R value or an L value
so there's no difference kind of in your
code whereas if you just had a reference
for example then that means that this
can only take in L values has to take in
like real variables can't take
contemporaries and by getting rid of
that converting it to be like something
else or whatever you're kind of now
accepting temporary values anyway my
point is it actually kind of changes the
semantics of your code in a way like you
can kind of do different things but with
a const reference my point is just that
whatever a const reference accepts so
does a normal kind of by value copy so
all you have to do is change the
signature and that's it what I think I
might do actually I have I just have an
idea that I just came up with on the
spot let me know if there's something
you're interested in instead of making
like a 40 minute to one hour code review
like I've been doing with like all these
different topics in it what might make
more sense is to divide these code
reviews into lots of little videos that
are regularly released like a few times
a week maybe that are like specifically
addressing certain things so for example
in this one we talked about whether to
pass things by value or by reference and
kind of how I go about determining that
I have a feeling that would probably be
more useful to people or at least you'd
be able to select kind of the topics
you're interested in rather than just
making a code Review called 2D flying
dog game and then
take the risk and click on it maybe so
yeah I might try that out for this
specific code review just because
there's lots of little things that I
could talk like 10 to 20 minutes about
and then what I usually end up doing is
not talking about everything I want to
talk about because then the code review
will be hours long and I feel like I
have to either put it into one or split
up into like two three videos instead of
maybe just by topic so I'm gonna try
that let me know what you think hit the
like button below leave a comment and
I'll see you next time goodbye